it's great to welcome to the program
today Liz wall who is a journalist
speaker former RT television anchor now
a candidate for the US House of
Representatives representing Texas is
23rd district which is a swing district
and we will talk about that as a
reminder for context Liz my audience may
remember you from my favorite RT
television interview ever
with a pro-north Korean westerner who
are sort of hard to find let's take a
quick look at that interview so we all
are on the same page well we here at RT
want to take the time to ask questions
that aren't really being brought up in
the aftermath of the failed launch Jason
Jason Adam tonus is the chairman of the
North American due Shangaan ideas group
and he joins me now for more welcome
there Jason so a lot of hype non-stop
coverage about this rocket but is it
possible that the fears are exaggerated
of course they are I mean this was just
a satellite launch something that the
u.s. government does all the time
Europeans do Russians do Chinese
Japanese so as every other country can
do this but not the DPRK and why not I
mean for example several other countries
have launched similar rockets and no one
really cares why is it portrayed as the
end of the world when North Korea
launches one exactly it's all because
the United States government and the the
other countries that are under the
financial dominance to the USA fear the
DPRK because it is a Jew che socialist
state whose very systemic resistance is
seen by the American authorities as a
threat to their economic system so
waiting for any progress it makes and
that we can also press go ahead
apologize and if any progress Korea
makes is seen as threatening to to the
American regime because ultimately the
American regime fears that if more
American people find out about the DPRK
progress they'll want the same system
okay has to be implemented in this
country and Jason can we also look at
this as North Korea trying to gain
respect for them launching a rocket
gives them a sense of national pride
well of course having a satellite
program gives any country national pride
but I don't think Korea really needs any
more respect from the rest of the world
the fact that a country doesn't need to
be treated good by the rest of the world
to gain legitimacy the only thing it
needs to gain legitimacy is the respect
of its own people but don't you think
that they would want respect at least
you know as a show that hey all these
other countries can have these rockets
why can't we of course they do of course
and so Jason what would you say then it
should be their rational right to have a
weather satellite like so many other
states do the United States has hundreds
of satellites so and the way can it kind
of be a double standard
exactly exactly there is a double
standard every country has the right to
do what it needs to do to improve itself
you know with the DPR why shouldn't why
should the DPRK be treated any
differently from any other country okay
Jason another thing that the backlash of
this is now the US has has declared that
they are going to stop giving food aid
to North Korea and this is food that
feeds a lot of hungry people and so do
you think then that is it a wise
decision to politicize this when the
consequences will lead to or in other
words politicize something that will in
the end take food aid away over over a
weather satellite well there's two
things to to consider number one the
whole food situation in
PRK is over height there is no famine in
the in the DPRK people have enough to
eat well of course they would like to
have more food aid you don't was sorry
you don't think that very you don't
think that there is any famine there is
that what you just said
no there is no famine in North Korea now
there is not enough to eat Jason how do
you how do you know that well I'm in
communication with people the DPRK every
day and they informed me as to the the
actual realities of life in the country
that I speak to people there all the
time they tell me that everyone has
enough to eat it's you speak obvious I
mean go there yourself to go to North
Korea I think it's pretty difficult to
go to North Korea especially as
journalists it's very difficult to
report on what's going on there well I
imagine there are difficulties due to
the fact that the government is a afraid
of spies infiltrating the country but if
you were to honestly go there and report
the situation you would see that people
that have a very high standard of living
there
okay Seoul is and let's just work
forward to you running in the 23rd
district of Texas starting with how on
earth did that interview happen like the
does someone come to you and say hey we
found this kid who loves North Korea
let's interview him or like how does
this go down essentially yeah that was
one of the weirdest moments I think
working there they say that they cover
voices that are ignored by the
mainstream media and I guess that would
be an example of one because that's not
a point of view that you hear very often
that one was particularly interesting
because that came straight from the
Russian news director and I think he
scoured the internet to try to find
somebody with an alternative point of
view I did not pre pre interview this
gentleman so him coming on the air I
only got his name and his affiliation
live on the air and then the dude pops
up and I'm like what is going on why is
this guy on the show trying to go try
the question that were pitched to me by
the news director and then it just
obviously went very off the rails and I
was like this this guy's on my own
he's saying there's no famine in North
Korea it was not a very very bizarre so
excuse the dynamics of because you said
the the Russian news director came to
you with it one of the things that we
often hear from from people at not just
RT but at a lot of these networks that
are sort of state-affiliated is listen
no one ever really tells me what to do
it's just I'm able to do what I do and I
do it the way I want to do it and we we
I've never been told I need to have this
person on or espouse this point of view
this was someone came to you with this
this was not something you wanted to do
no this was something that was we knew
that we were doing a segment on North
Korea and this was the you know this
wasn't a guess that I chose this one and
this this time that particular interview
was chosen but by the news director so
Larry King interestingly works for RT at
the moment I believe yeah and um and he
has been an advocate of saying that he
is not told what to say or what to do
and in a lot of ways I think that's
there is some truth to that but if you
trouble again
RT now it's almost indistinguishable
from Fox News they're essentially their
narratives overlap the attack on the
establishment on our institutions on the
mainstream media all of that it's been
very stark for me to see the way that
this media narrative has overlapped and
now we have the President of the United
States that we have an investigation
where a special counsel is looking into
his ties to Russia and more evidence is
coming out that shows that and that is
indeed when it happened
17 of our intelligence agencies has
having an even unanimously come to the
conclusion that Russia helped to get
President Trump elected by way of
disinformation and cyber madly
and we know that that's continuing to
happen and it's a very very start for me
because I ended up quitting and kind of
a very high-profile way in 2014 and yo
let me not jump ahead I want to get to
that but before we get that you
mentioned something that's interesting
which is the sort of similarity to with
with some of the things that we see at
Fox News here's what I would love to get
your take on because my I hear often
both from people at Fox News I've spoken
to and from people at RT that I've
spoken to no editor ever tells me what
to say or what stories to do or how to
say and as you say in many cases there
is truth to that what I think is missing
from that story and tell me if I'm onto
something is that if you are hired by
one of these channels you've already
been pre-selected because you bring
something that they find to be in line
with whatever narrative or positioning
is useful to them so that it's not
necessary for you to be managed on a
story by story basis and it's true
for example they would hire for the
opinion host you know you're on Fox News
you're gonna have took a Carlson or Sean
Hannity who was going to who was going
to toe the line and is going to espouse
conspiracy theories now taking a page
out of the Russian Russian television
playbook and but then people like Chuck
Smith that you know he is able to for
the sake of legitimacy so back in 2011 a
lot of the stories that we work
harboring did fit into that mold of okay
we need to do legitimate reporting and
you can certainly do reporting that
makes the u.s. look bad or a report on
shortcomings in our in our system and
then in our government and so on and so
forth so forth that are 100% true but I
think that it's since 2014
it has it has the type the way that it's
been about the gand eyes and the
aggressiveness of it and and this isn't
just in the United States I've done a
lot of traveling over in Europe an hour
allies are very concerned that Russia
meddling by way of new you know people
get informed it's and it through through
largely through social media their new
media through digital media that's why
Russia invests in 2014 and something
called the a troll farm where they try
to affect the psychology of the
population of a country and my
observation back then is that they
really have they really tried to amplify
the voices of the extremes so it's Trump
you know amplifying the far-right in
some cases actual people with Nazi
affiliations and we saw in 2016
Bernie Sanders went on RT after after
the deluge of media reports that I hope
to spur on Russian disinformation so so
you could see the way that they push the
extremes and the reason why they do that
is because it divides America when you
got people all the way over here and all
the way over there you're not gonna be
able to come to any kind of consensus to
come to anybody and you know the other
thing is just because oh okay
RT has one narrative and the programming
is based further that narrative it's
totally legitimate to say Fox News also
has a motivation and a narrative and a
big picture plan and profit is part of
it so in the same way that RT makes
programming decisions with one set of
priorities it's totally fair to be
critical of CNN for a bias to
sensationalism that drives ratings or
Fox News for whatever it is but the
point is we have to understand that
there either way there is a narrative
and it's a matter of figuring out which
one are you either willing or unwilling
to be a participant and it's not an
objective determination as to which is
good or bad but ignoring the fact that
it's real is what the problem I have is
well I think I think that you bring up
something very important because there's
I think
losing sight of the difference between
facts and opinion and a lie or a
distortion FoxNews and I mean we have
Sean Hannity spreading conspiracy
theories and spread the south rich
conspiracy theory this whole deep state
thing so forth and so on and you know
it's a one thing also that is troubling
to me is the way conspiracy theories
have been kind of integral to to Russian
media because there's this kind of like
what like why for example there was one
host that was came from a 9/11 truther
her background and it's like well what
advantage does Russia have by spreading
conspiracy theories nonsense conspiracy
theories because at the end of the day
not everybody has double lead even every
element of a conspiracy theory but it's
a kind of break down that trust in our
government in our institutions in our
media in the system to try to galvanize
people to overthrow the system and
create these divisions within our own
country and I think we're seeing that
today in our own politics
it's divided our country is more divided
or along even in comparison I think is
is troubling since the Civil War and
that and that's something that has been
a goal of Russian media and a goal of
our foreign adversaries and I think
other adversaries like Iran and Russia
are taking notes and saying and seeing
how they can use new media to divide
America from within and to make it so
they prop up people that are on either
extreme end of the political spectrum
and and make it so we're not able to
progress or unite as a country but to be
divided from within it to be divided
from our allies yeah I mean this is
literally out of the 1997 book
foundations of geopolitics as to how to
sort of further unrest within a country
and media is obviously obviously a part
of that now what was the so you you as
you said you prominently very loudly
resigned your position at RT on air
during during a segment what
what can we say about what happened
after that in terms of how it impacted
your career and sort of what the
feedback and blowback was yeah I mean it
I mean I think I'm proud that I did it
it was certainly not easy because this
was around this was in 2014 so a lot of
people were not aware of what distant
Russian disinformation was the way that
troll and bot systems operate so it was
very difficult to deal with that kind of
people spreading like people it's
they're called useful idiots we're
essentially Russia
what will amplify people that are that
will already spread hateful content or
have anti-nato anti-eu anti-american and
beliefs or conspiratorial beliefs and so
this is kind of this this elaborate
system where people will try or where
Russians the Russian troll farm and
their directors will try to discredit
good people in the case of the 2016
election they amplify Trump because they
thought well I mean if they want to get
Trump elected you have to ask why
probably because it's not in the best
interest of our country and so that was
difficult for me I think because there
wasn't a lot of awareness in the u.s. it
was more so if you go to Europe and the
Baltic countries for example where
Russia is right there they're very
keenly aware of this type of information
warfare essentially they call it hybrid
warfare where you know you don't have to
use guns or weapons or traditional modes
of military force but you can use you
can bort you can use words you can use
media you can use technology you can win
over hearts and minds so you don't need
to you don't need to resort to other
traditional tactics to influence the
policy of other countries so I think so
I can so that you you had asked
I mean I'm looking now where we stand
today in 2019 I am very proud of the
fact that I stood up up and was able to
bring attention to that it certainly
hasn't been easy um you know I've been
attacked by all you know my character
has been has been tracked my motivations
have been attacked but at the end of the
day but it also it also provided me a
platform and an opportunity to spread
awareness about what I believe is one of
our top national security issues and
that is our that our democracy is under
attack and this is coming from our US
intelligence agencies and it's been
reiterated recently and 2020 is coming
around and they're gonna try the same
tactics they're probably gonna try to
hone them and they're gonna use new
technology to the best of their
advantage to influence and meddle in our
politics so we need to be aware of that
and do what we can as as citizens as
journalists as leaders government
leaders spread awareness on this as tech
companies also to understand that this
is part of an assault on our democracy
and trying to meddle in our sovereign
elections and along those lines you are
now a candidate in Texas 23rd district
there's this sometimes here in Boston we
might just assume that all of Texas is
just red and very very red but actually
there are purple and even some sort of
blueish
enclaves in Texas so talk about this is
this what what is your approach for this
campaign and what in particular about
that 23rd district is an interesting
place for people who are more
progressively minded to run well I think
what I mean one thing that makes this
district noteworthy and important is it
is it's a swing district
so it's winnable Texas picked up a few
seats in Congress and the this last
midterm election I think Texas is going
it's some say it's purple I think it's
only a matter of time due to
demographics young people there are
our gonna get it older and my this
district in particular is 70 percent
Hispanic is the border district it's a
swing district so I think it's
absolutely a way to it's it's up for
grabs essentially and I think in this
Trump era come 2020 that we need to have
all hands on deck and we need to get as
many Democrats in Congress to serve as a
check on the executive branch as a
co-equal co-equal branch of government
and we need people to stand and you know
of course I believe in progressive
platforms in terms of you know when it
comes to health care preserving the
Affordable Care Act yeah
helping to to boost the middle class all
of those things but I'm not going to be
too shy and saying that I believe that
our democracy is under attack and we
need to be more aggressive in exposing
that and and communicating that to the
public because I think largely a lot of
the public doesn't understand the extent
to which the Muller investigation has
produced indictments and has linked
activity on high levels to to Russia so
it's so I think that we need to be able
to communicate that to the country that
our democracy is under attack and the
law is at stake in 2020 and and I
decided I live here now it's home and
because it's a seat that is winnable and
because I am so passionate about these
issues and you know woke up in 2016
after the election very distraught kind
of having watched the way the campaign
played out knowing and seeing you know
Paul Manning for Mike Michael Flynn just
the way that the Russia narrative and
the GOP narrative started to co-mingle
like they think they were they were one
it was one narrative and then it's been
a disaster Everson
our country's divided in El Paso
actually president Trump is going to be
there on Monday yes he will giving
because I'll be holding a rally to
support the wall I don't know well I
don't know if you people are gonna be
busts in but there isn't support for the
wall in in El Paso I spoke to a
representative from the Texas Democratic
Party there in El Paso
they are expecting protests and I do
plan on being there so it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
apparently President Trump thought San
Antonio there that week that we had
walls around San Antonio which there's
not I can confirm that yes not us not
not exactly the most geographically
well-versed president I think is is fair
to say well I think that the the turn
Texas blue movement is an interesting
one that we've been following and will
continue to but for today we've been
speaking with Liz Wahl journalists
Speaker former RT television anchor now
running for the US House of
Representatives representing the 23rd
district in Texas Liz wall calm and at
wall W AHL so that's the wall I'm good
this is so cheesy but um somebody
requests had suggested the only wall
Texas needs but sorry about that check
it out thanks Liz